[Music]
ben joins us in spokane washington ben
welcome to the show
hey thank you so much for having me sure
how can we help
all right um my name is ben i'm 19. i
have about 10 000 in investments and
about 5 000 in cash and i'm debt free
i just recently got my uh first credit
card and i'm having a really hard time
going against my saving instinct it was
just something my parents kind of
pressured me into getting
and i just am having a really hard time
understanding
why i need this un
tangible thing called credit ben you are
speaking my how do i overcome this okay
so the truth is and uh your parents are
very well meaning and they love you but
they fell for the trap and here's the
trap telling your kid they have to get a
credit card and why did they tell you to
get a card ben
uh to build up credit boom to get your
credit score up and why do you need a
high credit score
to pay for a house
to get a loan
to get loans
that's the only thing you need a credit
score for and the truth is you don't and
i can tell you this because i am a
practitioner of this i was able to get
my mortgage which is now paid off
without any credit score
wow is that shocking so
hey
why
does
everyone just seem to have a credit card
then it just
it seems then we are asking the same
question every day on the ramsay it's
called marketing think about how i want
you to watch tv the next three or four
nights you youngsters don't watch
network tv watch how many commercials
there are for a credit card
it's insane there's a
a lot do you would your parents sit down
and listen to a podcast with you just
one episode
yeah okay
i'm gonna point you in the direction of
my podcast the fine print episode seven
is called the dirty truth behind your
credit score and if you want to talk
credit card rewards episode 2 is titled
the true cost of credit card rewards so
if you want to have a fun hour listen to
both of those episodes with them and we
dig into all of those myths about credit
and your parents are are not dumb people
they're smart but they just fell for the
normal american traps
of well you got to have your credit
score to build your credit and how do
you do that well you got to go into debt
and you got to pay it perfectly and get
more debt so you can get a perfect
credit score but everything that they
say you can't do without a credit score
i have done i am like a unicorn ken it's
amazing i rent cars i rent hotels i
bought a house i pay cash for cars which
means they don't need to look at my
credit score which by the way is
invisible ben are you hearing this
george is living outside the matrix
you can too
episode 7 of the fine print i'm not
kidding you your parents will actually
like it george is very entertaining as
you can see it's a blast it's a great
listen and i think it'll be fun now
don't sit there and go i told you mom
and dad let them listen to it and
process it but then as soon as the
episode is done i want you to cut up the
credit card in front of them
and say i love you guys
film it and then send it to me on
instagram george campbell i'd love to
see that this is gonna be fun i can't
wait ben thanks so much for the call man
you're doing great but don't fall for
the traps this is the ramsay show